hello everyone and welcome back to the
1972 World Chess Championship match
between Robert James Fischer and Boris
OCD it's passkey it's a game 18 and if
you've been with us so far you know that
Fischer is three points in lowly elite
still it's 10 to 7 and the spot he
definitely has to start doing something
as you know there are not infinite games
in this match and as the war is going on
over the board is going off the board as
well
Fischer is still requesting that even
more audience be removed from the plane
hall and now he wants I don't know how
how much is that in seats but at least
30 meters in the in the playing hall
that there is not a single spectator as
he and his lawyer put it the previous
game they played sounded like a ballgame
in Milwaukee and while the organizers
did agree to this
a lot of Schmidt did agree to this and
they were removed but they squeezed all
of the seats together so they don't lose
even more money from the entries but
then the Soviet side also protested to
this as they were not consulted about
this and then water Schmidt has to move
all of the seats back and interestingly
when Fischer got back to the playing
hall he even commended a lot of meat on
how the playing conditions were now much
better and he wasn't even worried about
it worse anyone was sitting it was only
at one point in this game that he called
the chief arbiter lost arm it and he
requested one person to be removed as
Fischer stated he heard him snoring
water Schmidt went all around the
playing hall but he could not find this
one person that was snoring and that was
basically it
by this and also we mentioned during
game 17 it was the first time Fischer
came on time not to the game but to the
continuation of the adjourned of the
adjourned game but for this game he was
again late some 8 minutes
so Fischer is a
probably tired as well of these drawers
and he wants to try and make something
happen
Spassky has to make something happens so
this game we have E 4 by Fischer for his
first move and c5 by Spassky so we
definitely know that there will be a
fight it will be interesting to see
whether Fischer will try again for his
saucing attack with Bishop to c4 like in
game 4 which didn't go all that well for
him or will he try something else so
let's see what happens the Sicilian
defense is on the board we have Knight
f3 d6 Knight the c3 knife the c6 will be
for C captors Knight captures knife to
f6 and here Fischer doesn't go for
Bishop to c4 this awesome attack like in
the game for but rather for the first
time in his career he goes for the
Richter rouser attack with the Bishop to
g5 and it seems this this is becoming a
theme of this world championship match
Fischer does not repeat openings and ok
we have e 6 the classical continuation
to the wrist arouser Queen to d2 we have
a 6 in the now castles and Bishop to d7
this was this ace sorry about that
whoa and this a 6 move is a preparation
for this Bishop to d7 as you don't want
to allow this nice to come to b5
we have Bishop to e7 sorry with f4
Bishop to e7 and now comes Knight back
to f3 Fischer wants to gain further
control of the e5 square and now II five
is definitely a threat
we have b5 expanding on the Queen side
and also preparing b4 and here we have
Bishop captures on f6 by Fischer he 5 is
you know you always have to see if this
is playable if you push a 5 then your
opponent of course will push b4 and then
if you have this position over the board
and you will calculate I do this he does
that I do this this he does that and
then you'll waste like an hour of your
time on the clock but here actually e
captures B captors and c3 Queen captures
and after G captures on f6 Bishop to h4
d5 can be played by black and black will
have a very nice position here so after
b5 Bishop captures on f6 by Fischer we
have G captors on f6
I'm not the bishop Capra's on f6
captors on f6 does seem to be an
interest in pawn sacrifice for example
Queen captures and now before but after
Knight to a4 Bishop to e7 attacking the
Queen and now White has this Queen
captures on b7
the Queen captures and now rook captures
on b7 King captures Knight b6 check King
c7 attacking the knight Knight captures
rook rook atrás Knight and black doesn't
seem to have any compensation for that
for his sacrifice bone so after a bunch
of captures we'll have G captures on f6
and now comes Bishop to d3 this Bishop
to d3 is Fischer's novelty in this
position of Director Rosser previously
instead of this Bishop to d3 MU f5 was
played one of the more famous games is a
game towel played against Donald Byrne
in the have an Olympiad in 1966 and the
idea starts at the attack in the center
immediately and after this G pawn is put
forwarded this Bishop can be developed
to h3 but here we have this completely
new idea simply developing a piece
Bishop to d3 Spassky replies with Queen
to a5 a very nice move that no it
doesn't pin the night but if the knight
moves queen can capture Queen and also
the knight moves da to point is
unprotected so King to b1 a very
important move by Fischer giving further
protection to the a to pawn and now if
the c3 Knight moves then Queen captures
and e2 will not come with check this is
very important in positions like these
we have before now comes nice to e2 and
now Queen to c5
a much more active square for spassky's
Queen and also by playing Queen to c5 he
makes room for this pawn
so this pawn can now start marching up
the board or down the board however you
want to look at it and finally f5 by
Fisher we have if we have 85 by Spassky
now he of course Fischer wants to attack
in the center and Spassky wants to
attack on the Queen side spots kisses
position here is quite quite good he
does have the bishop pair although at
the moment it's not really doing all
that much but if he can activate the
bishops and then he should be better and
if Fischer will be able to open up the
center and spots this King will have to
stay in the center then it will be a
problem for him
as you can see spassky's rooks are still
not connected
we have knife to a four by Fisher and
now comes a four and rope the c1
preparing to meet moves like b3 would
see captures this will open up the C
file and also meeting moves like a 3
would be 3 will also be very nice and
here black will have nothing better than
Queen C 3 captures captures and after
something like Bishop to c4 the c3 pawn
will now become very weak so I have to
look to see 1 we have rook to b8
preparing to attack on the further
attack on the Queen side and now comes
c3 Fischer would now like to open up at
the C file and Spassky closes it if see
if pawn captures on c3 then rook
captures attacking the Queen Queen
before the other look is coming to c1
this will have this will be too much
activity for white and Fischer's
position will be much better here so
after c3 we have
b3 by Spassky and now simply a3 Fischer
closes the Queen side completely and now
while there are no more threats he has
to look out for Spassky will not be able
to attack on the Queen side anymore
he does have to be careful of some
sacrifices of course but now Fischer can
you know shift his attention towards the
attack in the center of the board
we have Knight to e5 hoping to exchange
some further pieces but also if Fischer
doesn't want to which he doesn't look H
2 F 1 now comes Knight to c4
it comes with an attack on the Queen but
this is not the main issue here really
if you play something like Queen to f2
and offer a trade of Queens then you
have to be very careful of moves like
Knight captures on a3 with check and I
sacrifice pawn captures Queen captures
and blacks attack will be too hard to
stop here definitely worth a piece so
after Knight to c4 Bishop captures on c4
we have Queen captures on c4 and now
rooks e2 e1 shifting his again attention
to the center as there is no more point
for the rook to stay on c1 and this
aligns the rook would the King very
nicely and here as paska finds a very
nice way to activate both of his rooks
so he does have to connect rooks King to
b8 he's playing he's trying to bring the
King over to c7 and then move this rock
for example
be five and then bring all the other
rook all the way into the game King to a
one getting the King out of this light
square diagonal rook to be five
preparing King to see seven and now
comes Knight to d4 attacking the rook we
have rook to a5 and now comes tonight to
d3 this night is coming to b4 which will
be an excellent square for this night
and also from there the night will have
a very nice control of d5 King the c7
prepares pastas ready to bring his
daughter rook into the game and now nice
to be forest planned and here now that
Fischer you know dealt with everything
on the Queen side he dealt with
everything in the center of the board
the threat is of course Queen to h6 he
would like to infiltrate with the Queen
here Queen h6 Queen g7 so fast he has to
prevent this h5 okay g3 fermenting h4 at
some point in the future and now comes a
rope to e5 here fish removes the rope
back Knight back to the three forcing
group to go back and now if you go back
then Fischer will repeat and Spassky
will most likely have to be satisfied
with a repetition of moves here and draw
but as poss he can't really afford the
draw after Knights to d3 Spassky please
rook to b8 he sacrifices the exchange
but Fischer doesn't accept if Fischer
accepted this for example Knight
captures then it wouldn't really be all
that important for example pawn captures
it attacks the night you can't really
move the knight if you move the knight
the C 2 square is taken if you move it
to f3 then you no longer control the f5
square with the night or the rook and
then black will simply be able to
capture upon here so you have to play
Queen e2 attack the Queen that is
undefended on c4 captures captures and
now after captures captures you will be
you will play Bishop to c5 and a
friendly move by white for let's say
praying the c3 square for the knight
Bishop will come to c6 and spassky's
Bishop repair will be more than enough
compensation for the rooks as now the
only open file on the board is the D
file and spassky's
bishop pair will be controlling it
excellently so a troop to be 8 official
doesn't accept spassky's offer of the
exchange a rather queen to e2 Fischer
shoots is
attention towards the very strong queen
on c4
we have rook rook back to a5 and do not
come spawn captors on e6 if Knights the
b4 now then then Queen captures only to
Knight captures and then the shop to b5
can be very annoying so instead F
captures and he sits by Fischer we have
F captures and e6 and now rook to f2 a
very nice move that simply moves the
rook out of the slide square diagonal so
Bishop to b5 will not be a nuisance
anytime in the future and here we have e
5 Spassky has an idea he lost Knight to
a5 but he already decided to give up the
light square Bishop we have Knight to f5
Bishop captures pawn rook captures and
now comes d5 this is the move Spassky
had in mind to break through Fischer
center but this is the problem he
captures on d5 and now it was most
likely in this moment as a glitch
mentions in his book that's passed we
saw that rook captures on d5 was not
playable due to this very unpleasant
Knight to f4 move and now your book is
under attack here of course you cannot
capture as the Queen on c4 is undefended
and you can't capture the Queen if you
capture the Queen then first you get
Knight captures on d5 with check and
only then white will recapture the Queen
so you'll have to play something like
rook to c5 to defend your Queen and then
comes Queen to f3 again you cannot
capture the night as there are simply
too many threats like rook captures on
a7 so I have to rook to b8 you will play
nice to g6 and now there are too many
threats here the bishop is under attack
you can't defend it because white will
simply capture it and then the f6 bone
will be undefended now it's attacked
twice if you move the bishop then white
has so many options here it will be a
much better position for white he can
capture on f6 he can capture on h5 you
can play rook to e4 to attack the Queen
followed by Queen e2 to infiltrate
blacks position here it will simply be
very very unpleasant for black so it's
basically decided not to capture with
the rook but rather would the Queen and
now comes Knight the b4 by Fischer also
Knight to be 4 isn't it the only good
move
you can also play see for grab a lot
more space here of course you cannot
capture because the rope to see one will
win the Queen here night to the f4 also
a very nice idea here still you cannot
capture rook captures queen but Fischer
decides to go for this Knights the b4
and okay Queen to d7 are getting the
Queen out of the way with an attack on
the rook you can't capture the knight
immediately if Bishop captures then C
captures here comes with an attack on
the rook and now you have to move the
rook rook a to b5 now comes a rook to d1
you attack the Queen and after the Queen
is moved Queen to f1 now comes with a
double attack against the f6 pawn also
look to see one is a threat you will not
be able to deal with all of these
threats so after night before we have
Queen to d7 attacking Fischer's rook and
here rook captures on h5 the commentator
said that there were better moves here
for example instead of capturing this
you could have played the in-between
quincy for check or simply rook to f3
and then bringing it over to d3 but
Fisher thinks this will be playable I
will have rook captures on h5 and also
this is move 36 we are reaching time
control Bishop capture Sun before C
captures and before would an attack on
the rock now comes rook to d5 now it's a
very difficult position for white also
as his King is a very awkwardly placed
on a1 you always have to be careful if
you move your queen or rook about this
rook to d1 rope the c1 this comes with
check King to b7 and now comes the Queen
to e4 and here it really feels like
white is winning you have this amazing
control black is stuck here on b7 with
the king your opinion his rook on d5 the
Queen has a beautiful central square on
e4 rook to h7 is a terrible thread that
will win black's queen and there really
isn't all that much you can do here but
there is one move that Spassky plays for
his 39th move and that is rook to see it
and now you can see that white is
doesn't have time for h7 due to this
rook captures on c1 Queen will walk
captures captures and rook to d1 will be
checkmate of course
as the point is covering the c2 squared
so Fisher doesn't have time for this and
he can't he can't go anywhere with the
rook along D and these squares as then
rook to d1 will be a terrible threat so
he has to go rook to be one but now
Spassky simply has time came to b6 as
the rook is no longer bothering him on
the C file this is a move for T has been
reached by both players and now comes a
rock to h7 by Fischer still looks like a
very promising position for white but
Spassky plays rook to d4 if you capture
my queen I will capture your queen and
now Fischer doesn't want to go into the
endgame although he does have the
outside passed pawn but his King is very
passive on a one so Fischer declines the
Queen trade we have a queen to g6 and
now comes Queen to c6 we have looked to
f7 going for this capturing of the f6
pawn if you try something like Queen to
g7 going for something like Queen to a
seventh and rook c7 will simply solve
everything for black so after this Queen
to c6 we have looked to f7 and now rook
back to d6 simply defending the f6 pawn
queen to h6 preparing Queen to e3 check
but Spassky prevents that Queen to f3 we
have a queen back to h7 preparing to
bring the rook over to a7 but now comes
the Queen back to c6 Queen to h6
preparing Queen to e3 but Spassky simply
simply blocks it
Queen to h7 we have Queen to c6 and it
was at this point that players agreed to
a draw as I mean they are repeating
moves so which I mean Fischer also
doesn't enjoy a draw with the white
pieces but he is three points in the
lead in this match the result is now 10
and a half to seven and a half so he
really doesn't really mind the draw as
you know the important thing is to win
the match here and become the world
champion but even though he's three
points in the lead and it's very
unlikely that Spassky will catch up as
you can see in the court above the board
I shall consider the match summarily
terminated and there will be no further
play under any conditions this is what
Bobby Fischer said to water Schmitt
prior to this game if the audience is
not removed
like he requested very very you know
weird stuff a lot of MIT really had so
much to do here and he is definitely one
of the heroes of this whole world chess
championship match
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoy that game eighteen of the 1972
World Chess Championship match between
Robert James Fischer and Boris facility
it's possibly really do hope you enjoyed
it
I would like to thank Kirk Siebert Elly
Martinez and Michael Hildebrand for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
or will appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos your thing
called for watching and I'll see you
soon definitely we'll wrap up this mess
before cross and Caruana
and but I will also check up on some of
your suggestions so to create some more
interesting content thank you all and
I'll see you soon